how's it going everybody Maxwell McGee
here and recently I had the pleasure of
checking out a bunch of new indie titles
come to the Wii U and 3ds this year and
guess what i'm gonna tell you about them
first up is a band hawkins and the
thousand-and-one spikes this 2d puzzle
platformer is an expansion band Hawkins
and the thousand spikes which actually
play it on exploit the new version has a
bunch of new shortcuts it's got new
characters which you unlock by
collecting these skulls it's got
cooperative play basically it's got a
ton of new modes ton of new content and
of course it's extremely difficult and
deadly next up is siesta fiesta if you
guys are familiar with the classic game
break out then you already know a lot
about what this game is basically you're
bouncing the little siesta up and down
either on a bed or in a magical siesta
cannon or on an even more magical hover
platform it's a very simple concept with
the way that these three different
platforms keep the cs10 play gives this
game a lot of variety there's also a ton
of visual distractions that gradually
build up on the screen you've got
splashes of water you've got confetti
there's basically a giant party going on
in the background all the time so you
don't want to get distracted next up is
moon chronicles this game is a remake of
moon which came out for the DS in 2009
but has since been split up into an
episodic FPS for the 3ds this was
actually my first time getting to check
out an FPS on the 3ds and I'm surprised
by how well the shooting mechanics
control the game broken up in two
seasons with each season comprising
about four episodes and one season per
year and finally there shovel Knight
which I only got to play for a little
bit but is amazing I'm sure you guys
have been hearing a lot about shovel
Knight over the year I know there are a
ton of people excited for this game I
only got to play it a little bit but it
feels great it looks charming and
whenever you start a new stage it says
sharpen my shovel which is just
fantastic basically it's a 2d side
scroller where you shovel fireballs back
at enemies you shovel gems out of the
ground and you shovel well pretty much
everything alright guys that's going to
do it for this quick roundup of course
there are a bunch of other smaller games
coming out on 3ds and Wii U this year
including Retro City Rampage DX Chantel
and wouldn't sensei among others see you
guys out there have a lot to look
forward to I'm axel McGee and thanks for
listening